ils sont 11 millions en france à
accompagner au quotidien un proche en
situation de maladie de perte
d'autonomie ou de handicap les aidants
doivent bien souvent concilier travail
et vie personnelle le gouvernement a
confié à l'occasion d'un déplacement sur
le site d'airbus à elancourt la mission
d'encourager les entreprises à se
mobiliser en faveur de ses salariés et
d'en prendre conscience que cette
politique est gagnant gagnant pour
l'entreprise pour que les collaborateurs
soit le plus sereinement possible à leur
tâche mais en même temps qu'il puisse
avoir cette conciliation vie
professionnelle vie personnelle c'est
ainsi que l'on veut travailler c'est
pour ça qu'on missionne vraiment cette
plateforme air est ce nous avons lancé
cette mission auprès d'eux
france stratégie pardon la plateforme
rse parce que nous voulons que les
entreprises nous aident à promouvoir
cette politique d'accompagnement des
aidants par le congé absentéisme
dégradation de l'état de santé des
motivations la mission a comme objectif
de lutter contre ces dommages en faisant
connaître et en facilitant les
politiques d'accompagnement en la
matière airbus fait figure d'exemple
l'entreprise a déjà mis en place une
série de dispositifs visant à soutenir
les employés aidant on a souhaité mettre
en place une formation qui permet de
connaître
les dispositions les dispositifs qui
peut qui peuvent s'offrir à lui ou à
elle également on a une application qui
permet d'y regrouper différents
dispositifs et ainsi donner une
visibilité à ces mesures des mesures
importantes pour que les salariés aidant
se sentent considérés dans un monde du
travail où on est dans une culture quand
même delà de la performance absolue pour
la reconnaissance quelque part il faut
qu'on puisse imaginer un dispositif
intelligent qui prennent en compte
justement une situation familiale
difficile temporaire est particulière et
que cette situation et neutralise
justement tous les critères de
reconnaissance qui aura derrière la
mission de la plateforme rse c'est un
minera d'ici le 1er février 2022 et sera
par la suite présenté au gouvernement